le patrimoine encore et on prend la
direction du château de cheverny comme
de nombreux domaines ses propriétaires
s'étaient préparés à la réouverture du
jardin 250000 tulipes pour le week-end
de pâques avant d'y renoncer la mort
dans l'âme impensable avec les nouvelles
restrictions de circulation aurait des
renault le long ruban de 250 tulipes
n'éblouit rappaz les visiteurs et la
nouvelle création de packs non plus
pourtant tout était prêt mais ouvrir
pour un public restreint à un rayon de
10 km les propriétaires des lieux et ont
renoncé
les jardins ils seront les seuls en
profiter ces prochaines semaines s'était
donné un mal de chien pour que tout soit
prêt ce week-end avec nos équipes qui
étaient en effectif réduit à 50 %
ils ont fait un travail colossal donc
c'était le désespoir total parce que
vous voyez toutes ses décorations de
pâques des yeux pleins les arbres voilà
tout ça au milieu des tulipes
on le garde pour pour nous deux et puis
puis maintenant avec le confinement pour
nous simples puisque les enfants sont
rentrés mais c'est tout à cette saison
le site devrait employer une
cinquantaine de personnes ils sont
aujourd'hui 14 pour entretenir les lieux
les propriétaires ont bien pensé à
ouvrir à nouveau pour le symbole pour
les visiteurs locaux
mais tout s'est joué à deux kilomètres
près blois est trop éloignée blois est à
plus de 10 km si la ville centre avait
pu être inclus dans le périmètre je
pense qu'on se serait laissée tentée
pour eux pour l'expérience
mais ça veut dire pour le thé pour le
territoire mais sachant que l'on pouvait
pas forcément compter sur une grosse
clientèle en tout cas loin d'être
susceptibles de couvrir des frais de
réouverture ne serait ce qu'en termes de
personnel pour éblouir les visiteurs
plus de 30000 euros avaient été engagées
pour le fleurissement et la décoration
de printemps du site
les propriétaires du château de cheverny
se sont promis de faire rayonner les
jardins à travers les réseaux sociaux